[Music]
okay just watch three two one
this is Thailand's McClung market
about an hour south of Bangkok every day
beginning at 6:20 in the morning a train
runs through Mae Klong Railway market
one of the largest produce and seafood
markets in Thailand through the stalls
selling fruit ice cream fish through
everything and if you're wondering which
came first the market of the train the
answer is the market
[Music]
the Mae Klong Railway built a commuter
train to Bangkok back in 1905 the track
they laid ran right through the middle
of this market which had been around for
decades rather than moving the meander
stay put
adjusting their business to the Train
times eight times a day seven days a
week
[Music]
we mean we don't have a planet Ahmadiyya
have some time municipal authorities
Kulak have had unique dr. Luke and
cooker sanity qualified Sekou lottery in
search engine called sanity who kept
pitocin monomer nothing your pension if
carnitine c'mon get fed peplum from ha
dejado Luca how you love sensitive see
somebody this system has been perfected
over the years with produce just inches
from the trains wheels tourists and
vendors wait as the train passes through
then everything goes back to normal or
at least as normal as an active train
new market can be
[Music]
when you Highline often you really learn
to train your fear like a muscle
sometimes the hype isn't the scariest
part
sometimes it's the exposure which is how
much space you can perceive around you
[Music]
my name is faith Dickey and I'm a
professional slackliner
[Music]
so slacklining is the umbrella term for
all the different facets of walking on a
flat woven band one of these facets is
highlining which is walking a slackline
high off the ground one of the best ways
to train for highlining is setting up
slack lines over water when the current
is passing underneath you you
automatically start to fall that same
direction and it's almost like you're
not in control of your body and that's
great practice for highlining because in
highlining when you're dealing with all
the fear in adrenaline oftentimes it
feels like you're not in control of your
own body either
[Music]
hominy is a town in the Alps of France
and it's one of the places that really
drives me in highlighting what's
different about highlighting in the Alps
is that the whole experience is more
intense being that high off the ground
you look at the valley below and the
houses are just tiny specks they look
like toys it's unbelievable
one of the high lines that I walked
recently in Xiamen II was uh Nagi
lumidee
and when we reached the top it was a
totally clear blue sky and we were
surrounded by peaks but during the
process of breaking the clouds started
to roll in it was like an acid trip
walking the line I was out there in
space and exposure trying to balance and
the line was swinging beneath me
meanwhile these huge white clouds were
passing and the line would disappear the
anchor would disappear and then it would
reappear and there was no way to control
it I just had to hang on the beauty of
the mountains is awesome and yet it is a
landscape that demands focus and respect
alpha and highlighting is the purest
form of the sport I can think of
[Music]
you know solving our shot develop
valuable Callie said na humane a glutton
hey girlies are ten boxes whole we share
picked up side note no bread makers were
injured in the making of this video as
you can probably gather this is not your
average bread maker nor is this your
average bread oven nor isn't your
average bread this is shot Esprit and in
Georgian that translates to well bread a
certain pacifist area had sent home it
was derivative itself in Hudson home
Akhil embraced and needs highest angle
rajagaha sent home
Oh Mary Hart poori at him he'll box
Weyland
oh nice our killer on sort of Taguchi
Lynette carve carve oval circle which I
visited since I make me mango pop
Shalini Tony stop she starts on a toner
oven is essential to the making of
shortest period after the oven is built
and the heat is turned up to the highest
level for six to seven hours the walls
of the oven are covered in a salt based
liquid and diving in to get the bread as
close to the fire is just a part of the
job
hearty tornado option kitchen cotton
ball over the s10 scores our few rank
bar home as if diving into a clay pot is
an intense enough this thing hits
temperatures of 750 to 900 degrees
Fahrenheit the end result is a special
bread with a salty twist that's eaten on
special occasions like birthdays
weddings Christmas and New Year's its
health stratum Souter is how to tell me
what to call it every which we do they
call this stretch of the North Shore the
seven mile miracle there's a world-class
surf break every hundred or so yards we
rescue up to a thousand people a year
definitely one of the most dangerous
stretches of beaches in the world
my name is Tao Hanuman and I've been a
lifeguard for 14 years here on the North
Shore I work here at a kite beach park
it's the home of the surf break Banzai
Pipeline which is a very dangerous wave
that breaks the very shallow water it's
such a critical wave that if you fall
down the chances of getting injured of
hitting the reef is very high even when
it's really small we have very strong
powerful rip currents it's very easy to
get swept out in the rip current and not
be able to make it back to shore just
yesterday the lifeguards made about 20
rescues
knowing that the possibility of drowning
is very real you know especially in
large surf we all train my training
consists of running the beach of
swimming anything basically in my area
we do mock rescues if the surf is big
I'll tell one of my partners hey go go
out and get pounded in the surf I'll
come get you with the rescue tube so
he'll go out and then you know he's
taking waves on the head and you know
see how fast we can get to them whatever
the ocean is gonna do if someone needs
help and you have to go get that person
you got to be ready to do that you're
putting yourself in a very risky
situation but knowing that your partner
has your back there's it feels a strong
sense of camaraderie we have a good
morale between us all we do this job for
the love of the job amazing even if you
can save another person's life it's very
rewarding for sure
[Music]
during a storm we are at war with Mother
Nature these avalanches can be deadly
and the best way to mitigate them is
with explosives here at Mammoth Mountain
to blast from the past we literally use
world war two cannons
[Music]
my name is Matt Seibert mammoth mountain
ski patroller not on any given day if we
can see anywhere between 5,000 and
18,000 guests we try to keep a constant
watch on the mountain and changing
conditions to create the safest
environment possible
[Music]
steep slopes large snowfall intense
winds are all recipes for an avalanche
[Music]
I've worked in our artillery program
here on Mammoth Mountain for the past
seven years dalit sir was originally a
World War two weapon of war now
discontinued in the war theater is now a
valuable tool for avalanche mitigation
our whole team feels secure when the gun
goes out and fires it's able to reach
targets that we would not normally be
able to reach with just throwing hand
charges our intent is to create many
small controlled avalanches as opposed
to letting the snow rest and winding up
with one large devastating avalanche we
fire our gun 90% of the time blind in a
storm without being able to see our
target we are capable of dialing in on
one tiny little rock and nailing it on
the nose the risks are real each day we
arrive at work we put our name on the
board for accountability
we go out together we work together at
the end of the day we come in together
take our name off the board and we don't
stop work until the last one of us is in
for the day I do take joy knowing that
there are families out here recreative
having fun bringing up the next
generation of skiers and snowboarders
enjoying the mountain it's a job I love
and it's my goal to create the safest
environment for our guests
[Music]